hasta ahorita el título 42 Todavía está
en efecto en la frontera quiere decir
que para aquellas nacionalidades que ya
se habían mencionado anteriormente Y
ellos vienen a la frontera a pedir
protección a pedir asilo se les está
expulsando todavía todavía no hay una
decisión como hemos escuchado
sea ahorita tiene la oportunidad la
administración el gobierno de poder
quitar título 42 totalmente y poder
empezar a reconstruir este proceso de
asilo para que la gente pueda venir a
con dignidad y con respeto
pero de expirar Este título 42 esto
representaría realmente un alivio para
los migrantes que buscan el llamado
sueño americano o no cambiarían nada su
situación con las actuales políticas de
la administración biden
Bueno mira lo que sabemos es que si se
termina título 42 ya no hay una excusa
de que no puedan venir a pedir asilo
Entonces sí vamos sabemos que vamos a
tener a más migrantes viniendo a la
frontera pero con eso mismo con con el
quitar el título 42 que ya ha hecho
mucho daño a los migrantes ha causado
muertes ha causado secuestros lo que
nosotros estamos pidiéndole al gobierno
es de que se prepare desde ahorita para
empezar a a crear infraestructura de
centros de bienvenida para que la gente
que va a estar viniendo a nuestra
frontera pueda venir a con dignidad y
sin tener que perder su vida sabemos que
la política en nuestra frontera
desafortunadamente es una política muy
antimigrante pero pues seguimos luchando
en contra de eso porque es un derecho
que la que el ser humano tiene para
pedir asilo es un derecho internacional
y que otras soluciones Creen ustedes que
ya podrían ponerse en marcha y qué papel
podrían jugar en ellas tanto Estados
Unidos como los países del centro y del
Sur del continente
como lo acabo de mencionar es empezar a
hablar sobre realmente política que es
pragmática y que es de un sentido común
donde hay que crear una reforma
migratoria para que la gente que ya vive
aquí en los Estados Unidos se le pueda
dar a un estatus legal que se pueda
crear una infraestructura en las
fronteras donde haya centros de
bienvenida donde se le den más visas a
las personas para trabajar y que se se
se reforce este proceso de asilo que
desde la administración de Trump se
terminó y realmente no hay nada que
ahorita se pueda hacer para aquellas
personas que están viniendo a pedir
asilo
y más allá de las políticas de los
gobiernos Cuál es la situación actual
humanitaria que se vive en esa frontera
entre Estados Unidos y México
Mira pues es una es una crisis
humanitaria ahorita se ha puesto todo
los esfuerzos locales para poder seguir
encontrando la manera de cómo ayudar a
los migrantes a que a que no estén
viviendo en las calles a que puedan
empezar un proceso de pedir asilo Ah
pero también la realidad es que hay
muchas personas que no califican para
asilo y que vienen porque el la realidad
en su país es que no hay trabajo
entonces nosotros lo que estamos
haciendo y Seguiremos haciendo es poner
presión al gobierno para que haya
cambios políticos tanto locales
estatales y federales